that's right isaac knows there's more
you said it
punisher
ghost rider
daredevil in blade
daredevil at the midnight yeah i think
we're all a bit more interested in the
midnight sun
this guy knows he knows and uh thank you
so much to danny loggie from strip
marvel for asking that question
seriously i love good questions
welcome back to new rock stars we are
one week away from moon night's premiere
on disney plus and now oscar isaac is
echoing actually speaking fluent spanish
giving us even more respect for this guy
man i mean i am uh i'm feeling feelings
for oscar isaac and every time he does
an interview he's just um eric i get why
this hero girl i mean before that
interview and after he spoke spanish i
have negative one girlfriends oh
surprisingly enough
i think i have a parasocial relationship
with oscar isaac someone who will never
know who i am but um
he's like you know for whatever movie
you put this guy in if i if it's a role
that fans kind of turn on like in the
star wars sequel trilogy or in x-men
apocalypse
oscar isaac still walks away from those
untouched he is seriously amazing and
he's several million dollars richard
hey he earns it here is every cent of
that he's amazing he's such a good actor
it's not even fair
well oscar isaac is echoing the desire
for a moon knight team up with the
midnight suns which in his view would
include punisher ghost rider daredevil
blade most of whom are now on his same
side of the mcu or at least soon will be
so
let's go
[Music]
this is inside marvel new rockstar's
weekly marvel reaction show and now we
are in the season of moon night this
week we're doing a preview of moon night
on disney plus coming next week mtv and
i are going to be here every wednesday
reacting to each episode as it comes out
and this episode we're going to discuss
everything we know ahead of this insane
looking series don't worry no spoilers
in this episode i'm eric voss here with
mt mt how excited are you for moon night
bro i've been waiting for the show
forever like i i think i tweeted back in
2018 that i wanted oscar isaac as moon
knight and it's finally happening and
i'm my heart is joyous and on the inside
so let's get it let's get it let's go
night let's do it let's do it and this
show just looks so different from
everything we've seen in the mcu so far
uh just a true character exploration i
think what one division at first seemed
like it was going to be before we had
the the sword camp set up a perimeter
around west view and then it started to
tie in with everything with the what
sword was doing with trying to resurrect
a vision and the scrolls are coming in
and we got a doctor strange cabin it'd
be like if if westview never really
broke out of that sitcom formula what
would it look like as an exploration of
a character going through this um
well while the moon knight producers
have cautioned fans in this case doing a
bit better expectation management than
what happened with one division this
series will have a limited connection to
the broader mcu oscar isaac is now
shooting the moon by indicating that he
would like to see moon knight in the
future team up with the midnight suns
instead of with the avengers which i
think is totally the right direction for
this character yeah but you may be
asking who are the midnight suns and how
could they come together in the mcu
that's where we're going to explore this
episode as we give you sort of preview
for what's ahead on moon night
now before we get to that there are some
awesome new moon knight hoodie designs
yes
at the hero shop check this out this
this is what it looks like crescent moon
on the front party in the back party in
the back chaos in the back this is the
black version of it there's the white
version that you can also get um which
you know it's just
slightly less cool so that's why i went
with this as it tends to be the case as
you've learned if you've watched inside
marvel over the past year or so but uh
but you can also keep an eye out this
week for our latest obsession moon night
shirt release the latest obsession
releases for one division and loki
hawkeye those all sold out folks some of
my favorite new rockstars merch on that
site so you gotta jump on this one quick
when you do you're gonna get the option
to write in a custom shout out that will
appear at the bottom of these episodes
mt and i are gonna read them aloud this
is gonna be your big chance we're gonna
put you on blast we're gonna showcase
you with whatever your hot take is
look i learned
last week just for this feature okay so
you better tell her this
trust for this i learned how to read
orabash egyptian
is working on that one
uh mandola language uh the scrolls
and aryan language but not english not
english arabic numerals none of that all
that was confusing to me not now not now
we learned it just to read your crazy
comments that you write i want to get
your latest obsession shirt um
well uh mt what's our first question
here well eric
the big question here is what is moon
knight about and when will he team up
with marvel's midnight sons team the
most badass of badasses yeah yeah that
is a good question there so moon knight
stars oscar isaac steven grant aka mark
spector he's a man suffering with
dissociative identity disorder one of
those identities is the fidgety british
museum gift shop employee steven grant
not saying the british museum he is a
british guy who works in the museum gift
shop but there's also the more confident
american mercenary named mark spector uh
buried in his subconscious now promo
footage tells us that we're actually
going to begin the story with the second
identity of stephen grant uh and that
stephen has no memory or knowledge of
his life as a mark specter of whatever
those past adventures were uh but both
of these guys their body is possessed by
the spirit of the egyptian moon deity
khonshu who is voiced by the great f
murray abraham on the show you may know
him from uh from homeland from a number
of great titles great he's on source
yes oh he's got a great voice uh now in
the comics moon knight really started as
really let's be honest a batman style
vigilante with uh the split
personalities of mark spector um who was
the the mercenary uh boxer you know son
of a rabbi uh but also there was stephen
grant who in the comics is a wealthy
billionaire kind of a bruce wayne
character which is why i think in the
show they're avoiding making steven
grant a wealthy billionaire persona
because that would just be way too
similar to bruce wayne um
there's also an identity that i don't
think we've seen in promo footage the
taxi driver jake lockley i don't know if
he's going to be in the show they may
just keep it a duality thing
hopefully by the end we meet a ton of
different characters who are in there uh
like uh like the movie split you know
the james mcavoy movie that also
explored dissociative identity disorder
do you really like james macavo went in
on that performance and oscar isaac has
the has the range to be all sorts of
types of people so for sure now in more
recent years of the comics this
condition has really been explored as a
more of a mental health disorder
dissociative identity disorder
previously known as multiple personality
or split personality disorder but the
the medical term now is dissociative
identity disorder because it's not like
you're being split it's just like you
dissociate from one identity and and
move into the other they actually did a
ton of research for this show into how
that uh condition really manifests in
people who are suffering from it as
opposed to like making it a parody or a
satire or something played for comedic
effect which i think is definitely the
right way to go here because it is a
real thing and by understanding this uh
this phenomenon it actually helps i
think people understand all kinds of uh
real mental health things other mental
health disorders that people are going
through uh because it's something that
like people are suffering with it's not
like the disorder itself is the
superpower it's in addition to the super
power so imagine someone suffering with
that already also got stricken with a
superpower how would that manifest in
someone going through that before they
ever met the supernatural element um
and yeah so that's what this series is
going to explore uh i would definitely
check out charlie houston's run of the
moon night comics in 2006 and especially
warren ellis's run in 2014 that's a run
that introduced us to the suited
detective version of moon knight named
mr knight whose appearance at least
appears in the series though we don't
know if that's going to be the sherlock
holmesian detective persona or really
just an extension of stephen grant's
identity we'll see ethan hawk is playing
the villain of the series named arthur
harrow which is interesting because in
the comics arthur herrera is really a
one-off obscure villain from the 80s
moon comics it's just one issue where he
plays like a nazi scientist um but in
this case hawk has said that he's basing
his version of arthur harrow on the cult
leader david koresh and as uh we've seen
in promo footage he's got a tattoo of
scales on his arm uh held in the mouths
of uh the crocodile heads possibly a nod
to the egyptian deity of amet who's the
devourer of the dead it looks like he
has those crocodiles on his staff as
we've seen another promo scene that was
released um and uh it looks like arthur
harrow from all this footage is pursuing
stephen and his ex-partner layla who's
played by meg calamali from uh the hulu
series rami also a great show to check
out um
and the the macguffin they're chasing is
this golden scarab artifact now uh that
is used as some kind of compass it looks
like now in the comics moon knight has
often been grouped together with the
midnight suns uh which is a group of
warriors who fight all kinds of
supernatural threats the the world of
zombies and werewolves and vampires in
the inside uh now
my most often this group includes ghost
writer as well as doctor strange as well
as morbius the living vampire the living
but in a different universe who knows
what universe that movie jared leto
version is going to be in um but then
over the years other dark anti-heroes
have rotated into the lineup including
blade and punisher and yes moon knight a
common antagonist for the midnight suns
is
our man methysto
um since of course it is from the fires
of mephisto that ghost rider is created
now in the mcu it's expected that the
midnight suns might have a different
lineup that's similar to the one oscar
isaac listed off there was a post-credit
scene of eternals in which we saw blade
meeting dane whitman black knight and
that might have been the first step of
this midnight suns process it's also
worth noting that that scene takes place
in the uk and steven grant like dane
whitman lives in london also works in a
museum it's not too hard to imagine
these two crossing paths so true and now
we got the netflix marvel characters
joining the mix including charlie cox
daredevil it's possible he could join
this lineup in the future as well but
really our hope would be that john
bernthal frank castle punisher is coming
back as well because i think he's really
a better fit for that corner of the
world um
at least matt murdock tries to stay
within the confines of the law he's
really a lawyer he's matt murdock first
daredevil's second i think uh so that's
uh not to say he couldn't team up with
them or partner with them in some way
defend some of them in court you know
help them out get them out of a jam um
now doctor strange or one of the other
sorcerers like wong mordo could advise
this team as a mystical authority maybe
not the street warriors joining the
fights in the alley as they're like
plugging plug in there i would like to
personally see dr voodoo introduce him
doctor strange too and then have him be
part of the midnight sunset
introduce that guy and multiverse of
madness and then tie him into midnight
sons i think we need to have some true
sorcerer in the mix there yeah um but
that leaves ghost rider now an agent's a
shield gabriel luna awesomely played
robbie reyes ghost writer fan favorite
uh there are theories that nicholas cage
could return to johnny's list
for a cameo in multiverse of madness
maybe i would love it i would love it
pretty wild
pretty insane i mean i loved what both
of those actors did i also wouldn't mind
a fresh start with the character i know
there's some you know uh agents of
shield fans are like it must be it must
be gabriel luna's version of the
character if he comes back awesome if
they want to go in a different direction
i'm not gonna honestly make make a ghost
riders project with all three of them
[ __ ] cage gabriel luna and this new
one it'll be fun yeah why not it's a
multiverse now baby all of them can come
back in some way but either way no
matter which of them comes mephisto is
coming with them yes you don't have
ghost rider without mephisto exactly i
think this is i'm getting into total uh
conjecture and speculation just based
off of how i think marketing tends to
work but the week after moon night's
premiere is going to be the first week
of april we're starting a new financial
quarter new ad budget kicks in in the
past that's when
marvel has made some big announcements
those that first or second week of april
that's when i believe we got our very
first trailer for thor ragnarok back in
2017 was the first week of april uh
marvel celebrates the movie sizzle reel
came out last year the first week of
april it's already been a year so i
think
what the heck
yeah so i think that's what we're gonna
see in the first week of april hopefully
finally a trailer for thor love and
thunder and some announcements about
what these titles are gonna be and what
they're gonna be called like there is an
unknown mcu movie that's going to come
out october 2023 i think they got to
announce it now this is going to be
blade
and i think leading up to that it's time
to see a midnight sun series on disney
plus that's going to feature yes we're
going gonna be in that characters from
multiverse of madness and from moon
knight and werewolf by night who this
october is gonna have his halloween
special uh uh jack russell right so this
is your chance werewolf by night is a
common member of the midnight suns in
the comics as well and i think they're
villain empty
why not mephisto it's gotta be the
physical this is the chance
it's this is the title where it makes
the most sense for mepisto to show up he
he's basically the thanos of the dark
side of marvel and like mephisto has
worked alongside with thanos in the
comics as well so like come on it's
gotta be mephisto it's gotta be he's the
most evil yeah he's the most evil so
what what um events do you think might
bring these two together like i
basically i guess i'm asking where do
blade and dane whitman go from there
from their scene in eternals
how do they meet how do they meet uh
mark spector stephen grant uh is it just
like at a museum a visit or something
like that
honestly i feel like this is all going
to tie down to
um artifacts and like blade going around
the mcu looking for artifacts of
darkness and trying to you know keep
people from interacting with these
artifacts or people using these
artifacts for for um evil purposes so
when we see um blade interact with the
moon knight he's probably gonna be like
oh that thing on your chest uh that
little crescent or like some type of a
country artifact uh you shouldn't be
touching that and like there's a whole
um universe of artifacts that we need to
collect and we need your help collecting
all these artifacts so it's gonna be
that probably and then it's gonna and
then obviously the ebony sword from
eternals the dark hold from wand
division that's another dark object and
so like in the ten rings probably
because we know that when woo
was in contact with this dark creature
in shanghai so like maybe that's another
dark artifact so it's like we're gonna
see this weird like um shield gathering
of the mystical um
dangerous objects rather you know
whereas shield would gather like the
technology and all the other dangerous
stuff like this is like the the magic
shield of like all right let's just keep
everything under control um so that's
where i'm thinking but what do you think
no i think i i think that's definitely
the right direction here especially with
the dark hold i think the dark hold is
going to be the key to a lot of it uh
and that's going to be like the central
element essential prop of multiverse of
madness that's going to
freak the hell out of every other
mystical authority uh in this realm uh
and yeah i think shangchi could tie into
that but specifically in the moonlight
footage we've seen this kind of like
council of other egyptian deities and
and their avatars right whatever their
earthly tethers are uh that kind of uh
that mark specter appears in front of so
i think like that's gonna be an
important uh an important moment that
just kind of outlines what the rules of
this part of the world are and what the
history of this world is and uh yeah i
think
whatever they decide uh whatever gets
decided with with like mark specter by
the end of the series uh i think is
going to have important implications for
every other mystical warrior who might
have some kind of like supernatural
demonic or spiritual uh connection uh
that includes uh black knight that
includes wanda maximoff agatha harkness
potentially uh i think we're gonna have
an understanding of how uh how their
powers work coming out of this show
um so hopefully it'll begin as like a
recruiting mission and the only the
reason you need a recruiting mission is
a threat to face i think that for that
threat is going to be clear after
multiverse and madness do you know who
could be actually a surprising a member
of the midnight suns that people don't
really talk about spider-man um because
like now that we know at the end of uh
no way home that this this a primordial
dark goo
of the symbiote is probably going after
peter parker we're going to see a darker
peter parker that is tied to you know
like the primordial darkness that your
nulls and like all these dark creatures
are a part of so the mcu could very much
be setting up spider-man teaming up with
these like other more gritty darker
versions on the midnight suns i think
that's entirely possible or how about
ned leeds my friend like that guy
right it leads team up
he picked up the crossbow right the
crossbow it's got to be fighting some
vampires like this is
it's hard because technically jacob
babylon's ned leeds is a sony property
sony studios film rights to this
character we just don't know how far
those legal rights go to when it comes
to a streaming series right because we
also have spider-man freshman year right
the streaming rights to these titles are
just a little bit different than the
movie rights could ned be lended over to
a midnight sun series i hope so i hope i
really do hope so i really do hope that
this uh introduction of mit at the end
of nowhere home is sort of this like
sign that like yeah we could we could
sneak them into iron heart
that's fine if it's streaming it's
different than movies so i would love if
the the sony agreement was different
there yeah um well we have a lot more we
want to talk about with moon knight
looking ahead but first we want to thank
some friends who helped us make this
episode thank you to sunbasket for
sponsoring this episode who's ready for
easy amazing eats sunbasket delivers
healthy meals so you aren't on the hook
to shop and cook to hit your health
goals sunbasket delivers a joy of eating
with bold flavors organic produce and
sustainable seafood and meats their
award-winning chefs are constantly
innovating with new recipes and global
tastes to keep it interesting each week
with dozens of options stop suffering
through sad lunches sun basket has
exciting new grain burrito and noodle
bowls for every day of the week try
accio citrus pork black rice bibimbap or
sit you on glass noodles just eat eat
and love in minutes and you can put
dinner on autopilot with easy to prep
meal kits that impress for date night or
win over the picky eaters in your family
whether you eat vegetarian paleo gluten
free or low carb high protein sunbasket
has something to check every box set up
weekly delivery and skip a week when you
need to it's simple easy and you'll love
it right now sunbasket is offering 90
off and a free gift when you order go to
sunbasket.com marvel enter the promo
code marvel at check out that
sunbasket.com into promo code marvel we
also want to thank peloton for
sponsoring this episode the main way
that you stick with an exercise routine
is to be excited about it if you're
dreading the boring and mundane exercise
routine
you're not gonna do it but peloton is
helping you stay excited to exercise
with their awesome app you don't even
need one of their awesome bikes to use
this app it's great for everyone peloton
is pushing you further with so much new
on content new classes new music new
ways to keep your workouts fun and
motivating they've got some awesome new
boxing classes that look really cool and
i'd be excited to try out you don't even
have to have any experience or equipment
you can break a great sweat and get an
incredible workout in your bedroom or
your basement it's easier to stick your
goals when you keep workouts interesting
peloton has a workout for every day in
every schedule de-stress from a long day
with 30 minutes of strength and 20
minutes of cardio or do a quick 15
minute total body class before work stay
motivated while having fun with bike
workouts yoga meditation dance cardio
and more visit onepeleton.com to learn
more that's
o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com and we want to
thank masterclass for sponsoring this
episode with masterclass you can learn
from the world's best minds anytime
anywhere and at your own pace you can
learn how to act from hell and mirror
and improve your cooking skills with
gordon ramsay or learn poker from phil
ivey with over 100 classes from a range
of world-class instructors that thing
you've always wanted to do is closer
than you think there are some really
great classes on masterclass that we've
enjoyed here at new rockstars there's a
class with former disney ceo bob iger
where he talks about them buying
lucasfilm and marvel there are classes
from mcu actors natalie portman and
samuel l jackson there are so many great
classes from writers and filmmakers you
can give yourself a decent film degree
right there on masterclass the classes
are easy to digest and well shot it's
not like watching a boring lecture or an
ugly zoom call they're engaging they're
really fun i highly recommend you check
it out get unlimited access to every
master class and as an inside marvel
listener you get 15 off an annual
membership go to masterclass.com
marvel right now that's masterclass
masterclass.com marvel for 15 off master
class all right getting back to
moonlight here mt i wanted to talk
through some uh other titles that fans
could read or consume non-marvel titles
to better appreciate moon knight because
it's not just going to be your standard
run-of-the-mill mcu show or title it's
going to be good to branch out into
other influences
we talked about split before split which
is actually a superhero genre uh title
it turns out it's part of m night
shalaman's um unbreakable trilogy uh but
it didn't seem that way at first and i
think that's what makes it great oh yeah
like when you went into it it was just
like straight up like oh this is like a
psychological horror type movie then at
the end it's like oh [ __ ] is that bruce
willis is this unbreakable my mind was
blown one of my favorite cinematic
moments ever like i'll never forget it i
love split yeah i mean and honestly as
much as i loved that at the end i just
loved the movie leading up to that that
it just felt like this uh this well
committed to uh scary scary story as
moon knight seems to be really
frightening um mae calamari called it
indiana jones meets fight club and what
i loved about that comparison even
though it seems like tonally kind of
bizarre to compare this together both of
those titles are really scary all of
steven spielberg's indiana jones movies
have very very frightening jump scares
in them uh and fight club is a very
haunting frightening movie uh if you
think about it more like so right in
that way yes uh something yeah more like
more like fright
[Music]
yeah indiana jones of course exploring
the ancient world uh that kind of race
to the gold uh treasure hunt uh i think
that's definitely gonna be a big part of
moon knight but then fight club also a
story about uh kind of dissociative
identities someone who doesn't
understand what happened the night
before having conversations with people
that he doesn't remember having uh or
ever meeting before um
and i think uh two titles i want to
single out are christopher nolan's
memento
and
the fx series from noah holly legion
uh which is a marvel title a marvel
mutant title by the way it could tie
into multiverse of madness in some way
but we honestly we could very much see
legion because legion was a fan favorite
show
that is technically the mulvar
multiverse so yeah for sure technically
you can go back to some old videos on
new rockstars where i broke down the
first season of legion back when like we
didn't even know if the channel was
gonna exist anymore and we were able to
do like one video a week so i spent all
that all that time just covering legion
i did episode one two and three and then
like the rest of the season i love
love legion a lot of people are like why
don't you do the rest of the series i'm
like well this became like a real
business and i kind of had to focus on
some bigger titles to keep the lights on
sorry but uh but i love that show i
highly recommend you check it out
because like that's the kind of like i
don't know if moon knight could exist
without legion you know like legion
broke new ground in terms of how you
could do marvel titles
like telling a story and they were able
to very
cerebral story like legion's basically
paved the way for that so yeah for sure
i mean momento really you got to credit
christopher nolan back in the early
2000s uh for breaking new ground and the
way these stories are told from point of
view characters not understanding how
they got to where they are in this
second you know the fact that trailer
footage shows oscar isaac in the
driver's seat suddenly with a gun in his
hand totally bewildered how he got there
i think that's that's totally a memento
thing right like for sure a character
who uh who half of his life he has like
uh memory issues and he cannot he has to
like tattoo stuff on himself to remember
and he's trying to piece together it's
like a detective scene that he suddenly
finds himself in trying to figure out
what does this mean and using it to
associate things from his past
reminds me of an old nbc show that got
like cancelled super quickly with
christian slater i forget the name of it
but it's like it's him and he's like a
sleeper agent he has two personalities
in his head and so like he goes between
like a normal dad to a secret agent and
i was like oh this is really cool so
like every time i see like a moonlight
trailer i'm like this is like that nbc
show with christian slater that i can't
right you mentioned christian slater you
reminded me of uh mr robot which i think
mr robot is another one of these fight
club type codes
absolutely watch
mr robot on usa an amazing series that
tonally definitely fits in with what
we're going to see in moon night uh
fantastic fantastic series there's so
much from wanda vision that pulled
directly from mr robot there's a whole
episode of mr robot that did the kind of
early 90s full house style sitcom intro
which we absolutely saw in wandavision
you know so i think uh all these shows
kind of uh influence each other and uh
tonally aesthetically
um
even in terms of the production design
so like that's why you know when people
ask like
you know like what are your favorite
shows to break down what are your
favorite movies to break down as much as
i love breaking down marvel and star
wars stuff these other non-marvel star
wars nerd nerd titles are my favorite to
break down because that's like where the
creators truly feel the the most freedom
and flexibility to uh to go into weird
places and not have this weird random
forced in cameo or awkward dialogue to
fit it into the continuity of the mcu
and it leads to weird deleted scenes it
leads to like some of the worst moments
in the falcon the winter soldier a title
that i overall really really liked i
don't want to feel like i'm hating on
that title too much but like there's so
much of that show that had to be like
edited down and and
stuff had to be taken out of it and
reordered just to kind of fit it into
the mcu and i think there was a better
version of that show in there that
didn't have to connect so much to the
mcu you know
into that world logic um anyway uh so
that's why i love like the opportunity
to break down stuff that doesn't have
marvel studios in front of it just to
have something different and just to
show what other great filmmakers out
there are doing that uh doesn't have to
fit into kevin feige's vision you know
or whatever it is um as much as i love
kevin feige's vision and i will watch
anything that he's it's a great vision
pga title at the end of
um i love it all i love it all i just
love a mix of all kinds of stuff to
break down anyway um once again that
show was called my own worst enemy by
the way my own worst enemy
yes we figured it out we got it we got
there
um if we're doing some required reading
in addition to the moon knight comic uh
titles that we mentioned earlier uh if
you like reading about egyptian
mythology definitely check out geraldine
pinch's egyptian mythology a guide to
the gods goddesses and traditions of
ancient egypt uh definitely great
required reading i would recommend in
high school i read edith hamilton's
mythology uh which is a fantastic
exploration of greek and roman mythology
and norse mythology but uh for to really
explore egyptian mythology definitely
check out geraldine pinch's work it will
kind of give you a
nice index of some of the names of gods
and goddesses and uh imagery that gets
introduced in this moonlight series
let's wrap up today with just some
predictions for what we might see that
we can create ourselves a little
scorecard at the end of the series mt uh
six weeks from now are you ready for
this yes let's go all right uh
let's let's predict which of mark's
identities will be dominant by the end
of the series who's going to be in the
driver's seat of oscar isaac's body
uh by the end of the series i honestly
feel like it's gonna be a perfect mix of
both mark and steven
um i think that
it's gonna be i think that the show is
going to purposely um establish a theme
of balance and like trying to get these
two to like start talking to each other
and start being um working together and
so like it's sort of how
having mark steven um be able to cope
with their you know their dig and like
you know basically show that like his
d.i.d doesn't doesn't make him weaker or
doesn't make him like any less of a hero
it actually helps him and so like i
think that
um maybe at the end of the day probably
stephen if anything if i had to choose
one um stephen because like you know he
seems like the the point of view
character that we were going to be
starting off with with the show um so i
think that we would probably want to and
like he seemed like a bit of an underdog
as well so like everyone likes to see an
underdog story go come come to fruition
and since that stephen grant is a
millionaire in the comics maybe we're
going to see his slow rise to becoming a
millionaire throughout this show so i
think that you know steven grant if
anything if i had to choose stephen
granth but what do you think um yeah i
think you're right there may be some the
way avengers end game ended with like uh
peter quill and thor kind of like
both of them in this sort of peace
agreement who's really gonna be the
captain but also we don't really know
who the captain is also it doesn't
really matter i think we might see a
version of that between the identities
uh within oscar isaac's mind i think
it'd be interesting if they wanted to
have like a post-credit tease just have
some unknown inner entity take over some
other new identity that we don't know
yet uh and just like the final tag of
this season could be like there's this
new character coming about we don't know
who they are yet but we're going to meet
them and oh [ __ ] here comes leigh sean
what's going on i'm the black
personality of newton
i don't know if i'd want to see that
just man what entire six episode season
amazing and then that that's what we do
before the credits just
he
never go full kirk lazarus everybody
just uh just he pulls a tyler perry at
the end
just really tries to get himself
cancelled
why are you doing this mark where are
you going this morning
i thought this is what you wanted from
me i can't tell the difference between
my waking life and dreams
somebody sorry
yeah uh
boy i hope not i hope maybe just jake
maybe just jake lost yeah maybe just
jake at the end of the day
here's a question do you think one of
the identities uh within his
subconscious might die or get uh
paralyzed or subdued or
that's it in some way you know do you
think they'll be uh removed from his
mind that is a crazy idea and i love it
and i would love to see what the
implications of that would be and like
how does he grieve over the loss of one
of his identities if they die like
that's so interesting yeah um so yeah i
would yeah i would love to see you know
what yeah i'm gonna say yeah that that
does happen to at least one of his
identities and like maybe he discovers
an identity from the past that already
died he's like oh [ __ ] he's he's dead
and like i
didn't really remember him so that's a
really good idea just like a like a a
headstone or a
you know or some kind of grave in his
subject in his mind palace would be
crazy so dark
oh my god it's so wide so cool another
prediction we should ask about do you
think moon knight will reference the
blip in some way
you know i mean it has to i feel like
you know given this point of mcu like
phase four
the blip is just too big of a thing that
happened like i honestly feel like
there's gonna be a blip and a tiamat
reference because of uh after eternal so
yeah for sure oh that yeah so i don't
think we'll see a tio reference i just
think i think every marvel title is like
i don't know how to address that i i'm
just gonna leave it in the indian ocean
and that's why we're on this part of the
world we're just not anywhere near that
part of the indian ocean like it would
be really cool if like because in the
internals we see that makari has a ton
of egyptian artifacts like it'd be cool
bukari's like here you go
here you go mark
take all this stuff
okay so you mentioned makari do we think
we're gonna see a major mcu cameo in
this show something on the level of uh
of don cheadle as war machine showing up
at falcon winter soldier or elena bulova
showing up in hawkeye uh are we gonna or
or even um uh what's her face uh lady
sif showing up in loki are we gonna get
a cameo of some other mcu character here
i think that there's either three
choices here we think we're either gonna
get werewolf by night because we're
worth by night we know that that show is
coming and that um the werewolf by
knights has very close ties to moon
knight in terms of his origins and all
that
but definitely blade is a huge um
possibility with the ending of eternals
and obviously again with the ending of
eternals black knight because like you
said um dane whitman is based in london
and we're in base in england and like
this character is also based in england
so it's a huge chance for for that to
happen but what do you think yeah i
think if it is one of them it's going to
be uh it's dane whitman or it's gonna be
uh mahershala or something like that one
of those two to to tie in uh but i think
man if they do
it'd have to be like post credits scene
like at the end at the end of the the
end of the season um but i'm not i'm not
uh getting my hopes up like i think this
story might just be its own thing and
then uh and then moon knight shows up in
the style
halloween specials yeah yeah absolutely
um now we gotta ask is mephisto showing
up in the show is it gonna get
referenced
in this show
you know what i would love if there was
some type of like um a god that was
representative of mephisto that like you
know the egyptians called a different
name that they bring up in the show it's
like oh this is this other god but it's
secretly mephisto i would love that as a
like a little um
easter egg but like
i don't think this show will see
mephisto but i think that's more of like
a doctor strange multiverse madness type
deal
but i think it's a there's a good chance
that we might considering the subject
but what do you think do you think we'll
see with this no i i don't think we're
gonna see mephisto in this show just
because like you know marvel i think is
doing a weird thing now where in their
marketing they keep showing characters
with devil horns and i think they really
are just with me at this point like
honestly i honestly think that they keep
they put this [ __ ] in trailers which is
a marketing choice and i think they do
that
strategically because they know new
rockstars is out there
and they know other other channels are
out there they're going to make a whole
meal out of it
when of course we know going into no way
home mephisto was not even though as as
close to no way home's plot was to one
more day uh mephisto's story like we
know that mephisto's not gonna show up
in no way home we know but this does not
gonna show up in miss marvel i think
they're just straight up
with me so that people will make these
memes on twitter and their in their
youtube trailers will get more views
like it's a it's it's a me message
it's a meme you made a movie and it
doesn't matter if i say in this what is
it minute 35
of an episode of inside marvel before
moon knight saying that i don't think
mapista going gonna show up in moon
night everyone on twitter and on reddit
says that eric voss is mr mephisto and
has been saying for months and
mephisto's gonna show up and moon knight
no i don't think he will be but you guys
are gonna say that i thought that anyway
the day that mercy
you're going to be so vindicated it's
going to be the greatest day of all time
i i don't even know how i'm going to
feel at this point because my
heart of hearts is that he already
exists in this
world and he's just in the shadows and
he's waiting so when i see him
i don't think i'm going to be like
shocked or lose my mind i'm just going
to be like
oh
finally where were you
i think that's all i'm going to do like
i think people there's all this like
uh cult of mephisto around me online and
i i think it is hilarious that i've just
become synonymous with mephisto but it's
like it's not like something i wake up
with a huge chub every day for my sister
um even though you guys think that's the
case the horrible fisto show go on go on
tag me on your memes i don't care i
don't care hey whatever gets my name out
there i mean i got people like
i i got people who meet me uh in in the
real world who are like so mephisto hun
i'm like
you really think that's what drives me
every day seriously
to finish my job
my wingspan
at board game on my on my ipad that's
that's what i do i like playing bird
board games
that's my world i like playing bird
board did you ever think uh going on
dates with my beyonce and planning our
wedding and then walking our dog that's
my world uh exploring the city of san
francisco i don't think about mephisto
that often do you ever think that 15
years ago the people would just walk up
to you while you were taking a walk with
your wife or a beyonce just being like
oh hey satan right pretty cool right
satan he's the best that's so cool and i
didn't even think that like a year and a
half ago when i was like actively a
producer and host at new rock stars did
not think that mepisto would become my
world
but just by making a couple predictions
while we were covering one division one
division being as big of an event as it
was
like even since then every marvel disney
plus title i have said
no i don't think mephisto's in this one
bro i get before tweets too
my friend what's it even mean
it's bigger than you and i it's bigger
than you and me empty this is just
something and i love it hey i'm you know
whatever it's fun
it's however people whatever gives
people joy exactly in favor of that it's
it's wholesome who would have thought
that uh people praying for the devil's
return would be so wholesome who would
thought wonderfully awesome
2020
well i cannot wait for moon knight
mephisto or noma fisto hopefully no
mephisto because moon knight's an
interesting enough character and his
world is interesting enough to explore
we don't know the devil in it yet
conscious moon fisto
he's already there he's watching it all
mephistopheles is already watching it
all he doesn't need he doesn't need
screen time he's good
anyway well that's it for this episode
of inside marvel we're gonna be back
next wednesday with our reaction to
episode one of moon night we're so
excited and then the breakdown is going
to come out i think we'll be able to get
it out later that day we'll see uh you
can follow me at ea vos follow mt at
mastertainment follow
new rockstars subscribe to inside marvel
wherever you get your uh podcasts or
watch all of our videos and make sure go
to epiccaroshop.com get your hands on
one of these hoodies
and uh and definitely jump on those
shirts when they come out you're gonna
love them we'll see you next week
everybody bye love you guys
you